what up guys welcome to Pearl daily
where I cover this week's treachery
debauchery and craziness before I start
like the video and make sure you get
yourself a women shouldn't vote t-shirt
as you guys know all the world's
problems started with women voting if
you want to be the ultimate alpha male
this Thanksgiving season get yourself a
women shouldn't vote t-shirt okay so
first story of today we have Diddy and
Cassie guys I'm going to give you a
timeline of and I I honestly I I hear
these people and apparently they're
famous I don't know I don't know who
these people are but Pearl's educating
herself today so sha Diddy now why you
would replace the name Shawn which is a
nice name with the name Diddy I don't
know I don't I don't really get it but
maybe it was better for the brand who
knows Colmes and singer Cassie
reportedly started dating in 2007 they
were together for over a decade before
breaking up in
2018 okay so we got this nice couple
look at she's very beautiful girl
goodlook guy you know we got we got the
couple wow look
it she's looking nice now I got to look
up for my my pattern recognition now
this is not an attacking anyone
personally but I look for patterns um
she doesn't have super heavy makeup but
it's borderline hoop earrings revealing
outfit all right in November Cassie
accused Diddy of rape and abuse in a
lawsuit Cassie known for hits like me
and you began her music career under
Diddy's bad boy record in 2006 rumors of
a romantic involvement with Diddy
started in 2007 despite no confirmation
until 2012 wow they kept it under wraps
for five years that would never happened
in
2023 oh I people can't even keep it
under wraps for like a month there's too
many phones everywhere they kept it five
year wow okay the relationship faced its
ups and downs with engagement Rumors in
2014 and a brief split in 2015 reports
surfaced of Diddy's involvement with
model Gina Hugh while dating Cassie
there were incidents leading to a public
argument in 2016 lending Cassie's mother
to call the police their breakup which
occurred in 2018 was confirmed months
later Cassie found love with her
personal trainer that's another Trend I
see okay the chicks you know us
successful women really generally can't
get men on their level in general even
Cassie who's obviously stunning and
beautiful and a good-look woman right it
it's still going to be tough to keep the
top five% of men I mean guys the streets
are calling for these guys imagine
imagine you're a guy okay and you have
the option to sleep with whoever you
want whatever look you want or forever
if you want or you could settle down and
get
married even women that are on their
looks level and really it's like a blimp
in time where they're on their looks
level I mean good luck getting one of
them to settle down I I mean I'm not
saying you can't do it I know Ryan
Reynolds and Blake Lively they got
married like some of the guys do it
Russell Brand and ends up getting
married but you know it's like what are
you the best out of the hundreds of
women they've had are you that special
now I can I can hope that you
are but I'm not in the business of
selling dreams you know what I mean so
again A lot of times what you'll see
with these women is they can't get the
guys on their level oftentimes I see
them going for personal trainers music
producers that sort of thing I've seen
this even with like less successful
women maybe women that aren't in the
public eye but I see this Dynamic often
with like lawyers let's say like I'll
see the lawyer go for the musician or
whatever okay so she married him in 2019
and now they have two daughters Cassie
later accused Diddy of abuse and rape in
a lawsuit while Diddy's Representatives
vehemently denied the allegations citing
them as part of an extortion attempt now
I have a hard time believing these
things if they don't go to Criminal
Court why because when you're going to
civil court it tells me you don't want
Justice you just want
cash
cash now I'm going to read you some of
the stuff that was in Cassie's lawsuit
against Diddy um so she says a few years
into Miss Ventura's relationship with Mr
combes the soup says he began coercing
her into to engage in the fantasy of
voyerism in which she was directed to
have sex with the succession
of male
prostitutes what while Mr comes watched
masturbated took pictures and shot
videos according to the suits Mr combes
called these encounters freak offs which
involved costumes like masquerade masks
and lingerie they continued for years
taking place at high-end hotels across
the US and in Mr com's home the suit
says that he instructed Miss Ventura to
search the websites of escort services
to procure male sex workers drugs were
supplied at these events which Miss
Ventura suit said she took because they
allowed her to disassociate from these
horrific encounters according to the
suit Miss Ventura would delete videos
from these incidents that had been shot
on her phone but Mr combms told her he
still had access to the videos and on a
flight once he made her watch a video
she thought she had deleted okay I'm
going to keep reading but I want to give
you my thoughts so far I mean this is a
pretty crazy story but I mean I don't
know how you can all right let's talk
about
coercion now I understand that women may
do things we don't like at times in
order to go for a guy we want we do
things that we don't want to do but if
my friend coerced me coerced me into
robbing a store am I not still
accountable for robbing the store I mean
I don't know how you can hook up with
male prostitutes for
years and then blame it on him okay in
one example the suit said that during a
freak off at a la hotel in 2016 an
intoxicated Mr Co comes punched Miss
Ventura in the face giving her a black
eye he fell asleep and she tried to
leave the room but Mr comes woke up and
followed her into the hallway where he
threw a glass vase at her sending glass
shattering through the corridor
according to the court filings the hotel
security captured the incident but the
suit said that Mr comes paid the hotel
$50,000 for the footage wow the court
finings said that in 2018 after Mr comes
and Miss Ventura met for dinner he
forced himself into the apartment and he
raped her after she repeatedly said no
and tried to push him away after that
the suit says she left him for good Miss
Ventura married Alex fine a personal
trainer the following year and now has
two young children according to the
complaint her association with bad boy
ended in 2019 Miss Ventura's case like
other recent sa lawsuits Su is brought
under the adult survivors act in New
York law that allows people who say they
were victims of sexual abuse to file
civil suits after the statue of
limitations has expired the one-year
window to bring cases under the law ends
next week the law is cited Miss in Miss
Ventura's complaint in a statement she
addressed with importance with the
expiration of the New York adult
survivors Act Fast approaching she said
it became clear that there is an
opportunity to speak up about the trauma
I have experienced and I will be
recovering from for the rest of my life
now I actually think this stuff probably
happened the the rape incident I'm a
little skeptical of but I have no doubt
that some of this weird [__] that
they're talking about with the escorts
but my question is at what point do we
have some responsibility for the things
that we choose to do and now Diddy I
guess settled with Cassie in less than
48 hours and you know there's there's
two sides they think oh he's settled
okay he's guilty I don't know I I don't
think she's as innocent as she's putting
herself out to be I don't think she was
just this innocent victim who was just
coerced into doing all these things like
to be with someone for 10 years and if
he's allegedly abusive I have a hard
time believing it was just one-sided you
were just this innocent victim doing
nothing and my question is if this woman
wanted Justice why didn't she go to the
police why does she ask for cash I don't
know I I have a hard time believing this
but you guys can let me know what you
think in the comment section okay so the
next story I wanted to cover was
something I saw when scrolling on Tik
Tok last night Kevin Samuels was so
insightful and that's one of the things
that really attracted me to his content
he would really break down problems that
we see happening in society and one
problem that we have really across the
board is that young boys and young girls
will blame their fathers for their
mother's shortcoming if the mother is
ever crazy it's always the dad's fault
for picking her if the mother ever acts
a certain way it is always Society
always finds a way to blame the men
let's pull it up boys in general black
boys in particular tend to hold their
fathers responsible for the failures of
their mothers and she told my dad if you
come if you come for us you know you'll
never see him again because you know the
media ridiculed me for getting the house
next door to himim to see my children
and they even said that I was stalking
her and her new boyfriend and I that's
that's how I knew that that my mom had
said that to him I said dad you know
they moved us to one of the most D
agreed upon to be one of the most
dangerous places in the world it's
almost like they tried to kill me or
something uh I said dad why didn't you
ever why' you never come to get
us and that's when he told me that's
when he told me that she was told that
that's what we that's what boys are
taught to hold their fathers responsible
for the failures of their mother meaning
mama can never do nothing wrong and with
whatever happened with Mama somehow it's
Daddy's fault somehow it's the man's
fault that's why it's so easy for them
to blame you even as an adult as a
single man who a never done nothing to
you that's why she finds it so easy to
blame you and not smile at you because
somebody somewhere a man was responsible
for something wrong in some woman in her
family or in their P
bull Heaven Samuels is right so many
kids are alienated from their
fathers they're alienated from their
fathers and they think that their dad is
the bad guy when really their mother did
not allow the dad to see the child so
many men want to be with their kids this
idea that men by and large do not want
to see their children do not want to be
a part of their children's lives the
majority of the time it is not a
deadbeat father it is a deadbeat mother
it is a spite woman that uses the kids
to get back at her husband and there's
an entire generation of kids that hates
their fathers without knowing that their
mom was the real issue and the comment
section really it it backs this up
morrice says I woke up this morning and
I realized that I've never heard a woman
say that the failure of her relationship
was her fault in person AAC says one of
my main reasons for not getting married
yet is you're not going to Guilt Trip me
for your life yes women are experts at
man
ipulation women are manipulation experts
and we always put it on the men it's so
interesting the amount of women I've
said I've heard say that their ex was a
narcissist when really they are the
narcissistic ones and I can tell by
talking to them within five minutes
because they only see things from their
point of view women are not taught
emotional control they are not taught
how to be in a proper relationship we
are taught that everything is the man
the evil men's fault and we were taught
this from a young age when anytime a
teenager was caught fooling around with
with the boy it's always the boy taking
advantage of her but we never talk about
the women that take advantage of the
guys D 925 said most men look for their
fathers when they reach 25 because
they've started dealing with women and
they realized that women are not
innocent and many times people will say
that I hate women that I'm just trying
to drag on women but if we don't
understand the nature of women and the
way that women are so many children lose
access to their fathers and there is
nothing more evil that you can do to a
child than not give that child their
god-given right to see their dad and to
have a good relationship with their dad
so many women are so spited towards
their exes that they give their children
a completely different version of
reality than what actually happened it
takes two to tango and when
relationships fail the women are not
these innocent victims that everything
just happens to and I see this time and
time again if I talk about a guy why did
a guy cheat everyone freaks out and says
I'm advocating for cheating if we ever
give the man's point of view then you
are demonized you are demonetized you
are whenever you advocate for men and
children having access to their fathers
they they constantly shoot the messenger
instead of talking about the actual
problem why can't we have a conversation
about the evil nature of women without
bringing men into it it's always but men
but men but men why why must why must we
speak this why why can't we have an
honest conversation about where women
fall short in relationships without it
be dogging on women we have been for 50
years we have talked about all the ways
that men fall short in relationships and
I hear the right and the left do this
you're not a real man if you don't do
this you're not a real man if your woman
Works you're not a real man
why why do women think they get to
decide what makes a man a real man man
and it's so interesting because I never
hear the men talk about what makes a
real woman okay so Andrew taten and
Pierce Morgan are back they're back in
Action they make such amazing content
together I love watching their
interviews let's pull it up things you
can do if you have hundreds of millions
of dollars where you said you had a
worth of 17 million no I said they took
17 million years so where's the rest uh
they must have taken it I think they
have it or maybe I lost it I think I
lost it somewhere you you've never had
hundreds of millions of dollars course
not we haven't have you of course not
you said they took all your assets
exactly well did they or didn't they of
course they took everything I mean
they'll be watching this are they to
assume that there are hundreds of
millions more dollars they haven't got
yet they're watching this that's right
they take absolutely everything you have
it all right but again is that all just
the smoke and
mirrors oh that's so funny I thought
this was hilarious so I don't understand
how it's perfectly legal because a man
says words you don't like on the
internet to seize his assets if this can
happen to Andrew Tate this could happen
to anybody and it's it's weird because
the older you get the more you realize
that there's no freedom of speech
there's no there's no freedom of speech
anywhere because the consequences that
come with saying what you think I mean
half the time the costs outweigh the
benefits it it leads you to being
demonetized you could lose your job your
family will alienate you there are so
many consequences to saying what is true
you know Andrew Tate says things that
are true and when I do Street interviews
I mean the boys love him don't get me
wrong but the women oh I hate Andrew
Tate I hate Andrew Tate and they can't
even tell me why they hate him we have
this visceral reaction this this gut
reaction where he is completely
demonized for saying things that are
true um so the comments section weighs
in on this Tate should have stayed quiet
and not boasted about his hustle he's
actually good for men in a lot of ways
but the establishment is going to use
all the videos he posted against him in
court um this guy is one of them this is
an attack not an interview I actually
from what I've seen of the I haven't
watched the full thing yet but I didn't
actually think it was a complete attack
sometimes I think Pierce Morgan plays
Devil's Advocate because as a journalist
he's really he's meant to ask the tough
questions the real world says Pierce was
torn between whether to downplay
downplay Tate's net worth or to Concur
and help dcot take more I mean Pierce is
establishment like he he does have
people that pay his bills so I do think
he has an agenda that he has to push um
but I also think sometimes he's he's
just doing his job so the next story I
wanted to talk about the double
standards in relationships I have seen
this trend of women being able to do
absolutely batshit crazy things and men
are supposed to laugh it off there are
many times where I have seen women hit
men and it's not supposed to count as a
real hit the women shouldn't be charged
with it and the men can't hit back how
the heck is that fair why do women ask
for equality if we cannot accept what
comes with it I've also seen women say
that oh I just I went crazy well why is
it cute to go crazy and and I've noticed
this trend over and over again if a man
goes crazy then the cops are called but
if a woman goes crazy everybody's just
supposed to accept it so I I met skyb a
couple of months ago um I met her
briefly after I did the no jumper
interview and back then I think I asked
her like what went what went wrong you
know what I mean like what
why are you why and she's like no I just
like porn I like my parents I was like
okay all right all right um anyways I've
seen her relationship with this other
YouTuber Nick Nena fall apart and Nick
is a YouTuber Sky Bri they were dating
now they break up um and I know part of
the problem Sky Bri was talking on
podcast how he would always make her
feel bad about doing about doing corn
but you know that's kind of the cost
that comes with it Nick says he really
didn't do that I don't know know Nick
really does seem like a standup guy he
seems like a nice a nice dude I mean he
was willing to date a porn star I mean
that that's nice enough you know anyways
I see a video of Sky bre stabbing a
pinata with Nick's face on it let's pull
it
up
[__] okay this is crazy I mean this is
insane why are you stabbing a piñata
with your ex's face on it if a guy did
this this would go viral everyone would
think he was insane and crazy um but
women they do this and it goes viral but
for different reasons they say oh that
this is they say that he deserved it
again being crazy is cute for women why
I don't get it why okay so the caption
of the video yeah man your ex skyb seems
real sane imagine a man doing this at
pearly things
appropriate now I deem this
inappropriate for a wife and a
girlfriend um ladies here here's a
lesson okay if your exes all hate you
and don't have nice things to say the
next man will take that into account you
do not want your ex-boyfriends to speak
ill of you uh similarly if you're
applying for a job and all of your old
employers fired you or they say this
girl quit in a terrible way or whatever
the next man will take into account your
relationships that you have with men
will will be taken into account when you
have future relationships Cura says
these industry demons are real bro move
out and begin the healing process bill
says she tried to trick you from the
beginning you trauma bonded with her and
now she wants to go back to doing the
same thing she was crying about yeah and
and she's not going to stop doing porn
she'll do only fans she'll do something
these chicks can never stay away from it
I mean I've seen it over and over again
Mia Khalifa went around crying about how
she did borne and then she's back and
only fan same with Lana rhods back and
only fans um half the times these chicks
are lazy and they don't know how to get
a real job they've been super attractive
from a young age they could have done
modeling which takes a little bit of
skill or maybe like pageants or
something but instead they choose to do
the easy thing which is get naked and
have sex but fast money comes with slow
problems and now you're going to see her
have a string of failed relationships
for the rest of her life if I had to
guess I don't know so um another clip
that I saw from the Andrew Tate and the
Pierce Morgan interview was Andrew Tate
talking about a woman that was like 50
years old posting bikini pictures now as
you guys know I have the EM series about
what is appropriate for a wife and a
mother and you know I think at 50 years
old you should put it away Andrew Tate
was called a misogynist and a sexist for
saying maybe you shouldn't be naked in
public maybe I mean is this crazy to say
hey ladies ladies all right I'm going to
give you guys a pass I'm going to be so
nice bro I'm gonna be like the nicest
you can dress like a [__] till you get
married now I'm not saying you should
but I'll at least refrain a little bit
from the shaming because you know you're
trying to get a guy maybe you got to
show off whatever now now again I'm not
saying to do that but I'm Gonna Give
You slightly more of a
pass slightly now I know all the guys
are like Pearl Pearl don't do it don't
okay but it's a especially heinous I
just want to say like like if you wear a
[__] outfit and you're single no
boyfriend whatever what we're going to
say it's like this heinous this this bad
but if you have children especially
children that are old enough to know
what's going on that's like this bad
like bad bad bad bad because guys your
kids are watching we don't want to see
you naked we need you to put the rolls
away if you're in good shape put the
body away show that to your husband um I
don't understand why you ladies feel the
need to be naked so bad like it's really
embarrassing it's actually it's it's so
embarrassing I am embarrassed like I'm
literally embarrassed For You especially
the older women that are clinging to
their youth um like they're they're
clinging to their youth like it's
the trying to think of an analogy like
they're they're clinging to the these
women are clinging to their youth like
imagine okay imagine um have you ever
seen like those people that are over
like a cliff and they're like holding on
to the Rope they're like oh no I'm
falling down Ah that's these women
clinging to their youth they're like
please please keep me young ladies at
some point you get old and ugly yes at
some point and I noticed this like trend
on social media if I ever put that
younger women were hotter than older
women they always throw the same stuff
at you they always they always do they
always get mad they always they okay
here here's what you do I'm just going
to show you something say younger women
are hotter than older women step one
they'll show me their selfies they'll
say I am so super hot and really
attractive and here is myself then step
two what they'll do is they will say
that you you can be hot until 40
something you can compete with those 20
year olds this is what I call the cope
this is I mean I mean you could maybe
compete with a pound of makeup some
plastic
surgery and you still probably won't be
hotter there's something about being 22
man I don't know what to tell you then
the step three is they'll they'll try to
make it a creepy thing they'll try to
they'll say oh you creep and then
they'll they'll throw some accusation
like it's just be and this is so crazy
how bad women just cling to their youth
I saw I didn't even watch it because I
just I just thought it was the stupidest
thing I've ever seen in my life this
Sydney Watson chick made a video called
the obsession with barely legal like
women and they'll make it they'll try to
make it in as a creepy thing and it's
really just because they're sad they're
old they're old they're getting old and
ugly you know I can't I I mean people
age people age and it's it's all right
now anyways so Andrew Tate weighs in on
this woman being naked at an old age
let's let's pull it up you you tweeted a
picture of Amanda Holden very good
friend of mine uh it's a very harmless
picture she's in a bikini on holiday
under a rain shower uh looking
extraordinarily uh beautiful in a sexual
pose and you tweeted you are a wife and
a mother and you're far past a teenager
there's no need for this post agreed
again it's just misogynist to say that
not misog kind a woman of her age she's
just turned 50 why can't a woman of that
age actually show off her beautiful body
in a in a nice bikini like that what's
wrong with that you can call me crazy
you can call me misogynistic but I think
once you reach the ripe age of 50 any
woman should not be interested in thirst
trapping on Instagram I think she has
bigger responsibilities I'm sure she's a
very intelligent lady and she's done
amazing things she's famous she's
obviously very capable and I think she
could do things more interesting than
standing around trying to thirst trap on
Instagram like she's 18 because I think
she's above it I wasn't insulting her I
was reminding her that that she's
actually such a fantastic person she's
done such amazing things in her life and
she's so achieved that she's actually
above thirst traic I was reminding of
her of her worth because as a feminist
we're all feminists here right we all
believe in women empowerment I'm
reminding of her her of her worth you a
feminist sure you're not though are you
I believe in feminine empowerment and I
think feminine empowerment is in yes I
do and feminine empowerment is in
modesty modesty is empowering for Fe for
females believe taking your clothes off
for men on Instagram is not empowering
EMP powering when you say no man but my
husband can see my body that is female
empowerment and I was reminding her of
that I was reminding her of her ripe age
and her intellect and there is no need
for that how old are you now I am 36 36
years old corre at what point will your
antics you know chugging your cigars in
your ripped body in your compound with
your security and your Bugattis at what
age does that become a thirst trap I
don't know if that ever stops being a
thirst trap because so it's fine for you
once again one rule for the man another
rule for the woman that's interesting
because I've never heard this argument
before but I'm extremely intelligent
I've already ciphered how this is going
to go from head to toe it's called I
guess we can look at peacocks right the
male peacock he shows look who I am look
look what I can do look at my
achievement look at my beautiful
feathers and I guess you could call it
peacocking to a degree I'm showing the
world I'm extremely I'm extremely
physical cap I'm extremely physically
capable yes that's correct I'm extremely
financially successful you stripping off
for Instagram is fine it's not stripping
off for Instagram I'm boxing when you
box you Bo no top on you do it all the
time with your cigar and you're showing
off your Rip but that's fine for you but
if Amanda Holden dares do it that is
apparently thirst trapping I think me
boxing with no shirt on is different
than a 50-year-old woman post you don't
just box I've seen you doing ones where
you wander around all Moody with your
cigar and your topless and stuff are you
jealous are you a fan Pierce uh no I
just think it's first trap do you yeah
well I don't do that perhaps it's
successful maybe you should
start maybe you should start that so
funny okay um number one Pier you can't
believe this you
Pierce let me back up let's talk about
Amanda Holden no no no no you are not a
misogynist for saying that women
shouldn't be naked over a certain age if
that's misogyny then I get I really
think okay I'm going to give you the
timeline now I want to say the ideal the
ideal is obviously to not be naked from
like the youngest like like I think you
know you should never dress [__] but
I'm going to I'm going to say what I'm
aiming for you know we can't go from
being completely naked to like nothing
right I mean being completely naked to
just covered up overnight as as a
society I really think over the age of
25 yes ladies yes it's time to put away
the skin tight outfits it's time to put
away the super short stuff I would even
maybe argue like 22 but okay we're going
to we're going to we're in 2023 I'll
I'll give you guys till 25 28 27 it
should be away You're supposed to move
differently as a woman with wisdom and
maturity and as you get older you should
realize that you're not supposed to have
all that hanging out anymore it's sad
and you look like you're clinging to
your youth for a lifetime you look
pathetic ladies I don't know what to
tell you okay so the comments section
I'm by no means agreeing with him but
I'm pretty sure Pierce Morgan have said
previously that Madonna and Liz early
should cover up as after they are a
certain age absolute hypocrite yeah J
yadida says men and women are not the
same they have different jobs to do
their rules of life and mortality are
not the same and as for topic women lose
their value if they show it women are
Treasures that need to be safe and men
get their value the more they show how
powerful they are tweep says who is he
decide what anyone can or cannot do with
their body telling women to be modest
after 50 but asking Pierce to start
going topless at 58 well I'm not going
to I don't I don't know if Pierce has
the body to go top I'm just I'm not even
trying to be rude I just I don't but
look he's not saying what people can and
can't do he's saying what is socially
acceptable and he's right ladies you
guys look like clown like I can't even
put into words how stupid you guys look
literally you y'all have all these Botox
foreheads I mean you you get all these
surgeries you have these fake eyelashes
this long hair hair all this stuff at
some point it's time to not be a sex
object at some point I don't know what
point that is I'll I'll even at this
rate I swear to God I'll give you guys
till 35 please by 35 put it away
please no it should be 25 it should okay
guys let me know what you think what age
should women put the boobs the butt and
all the away I know I know let's let's
obviously we want it the sooner the
better but if it was up to you what what
age does it start becoming sad all right
last episode our top comment was Iron
Mike Halloween this woman is brutally
honest and she is right what can I say
folks guys let me know what you think in
the comment section make sure you like
the video on your way out and subscribe
to the channel and get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt today I'll talk
to you next
time